foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello hello
[Music]
all right here we go we're live we're
live on our Lifeline show wow oh dude I
gotta tell you I don't know what's going
on but and I'm being for real my hair is
been really good lately it has I don't
know it feels more full it feel feels
you know is it my beard that makes it
that ACC accents it no
it's your hair yeah but I I just your
hair that looks better so it's your hair
that's doing it no I know but sometimes
you add stuff and it makes other stuff
look better like if you put on a watch
you look more complete disagree some
people think that you put on a tie it
makes a suit look better okay yeah okay
okay okay so it's like maybe it's the
beard that I think the beard in my hair
the Beard's framing the hair frame it
might be I don't know I I just my hair
has been good but here's the deal though
then I'll like I'll wash it and then
like the next few days it'll just look
bad or I'll uh or I'll see a picture
I'll be like I gotta get a cut yeah
washing hair is the end how often do I
understand end of it looking good yeah
uh I wash my hair
once every few weeks oh really yeah oh
wow how come you're gonna watch it more
you hate doing it I hate washing my hair
I hate the way my hair feels after it's
washed uh now what's gonna happen is
people are gonna DM me and say it's
because you're doing it like this and if
you do it like that it won't and I will
tell you all right now yes it will even
if I do it the way you suggest so please
don't suggested thank you
there you go thank you and you should
know because you're you and you're 38.
yeah me I I I I've lived many years as
you know as only me and I know how the
hairs on my head works and hairs on my
head work and you know that's that and
I'm just wondering about how like is my
[ __ ] getting more full like I should be
losing like I I feel like I love I I
love I did lose I lost some hair I think
in my or like when I was like 36 and
then I kind of stopped losing some hair
sick and now I'm just kind of like is it
is it like am I regenerating I don't
think you were ever losing your hair I
think that was I think that was a myth
you made up I did make I do make up some
myths sometimes yeah
um but yeah so anyway that looks good
I'm happy about that and it's getting
colder out right it is getting colder
today was the first gray day fully gray
day of the year and I was looking
forward to it all year and it depressed
me so
I'm looking forward to it that's just
how life's like it was just so [ __ ]
hot there was no in between room and we
love it and I love that I want it to be
hot only and I want it to be hot all the
time yeah I I mean I like it when it's
warm I don't like it when it's 100
degrees though which it was like I want
to be 100 degrees why why do you even
live here then move to Vegas
I mean where it's [ __ ] terrible I
don't want to go to Vegas because it's
Vegas no I like 100 degrees I wouldn't
want every day to be 100 degrees
obviously I want every day to be like
you know 76 I would think that would be
awesome for me that isn't hot though
that's perfect I'll tell you what 76
outside is not hot 76 inside is hot
people think that yeah why is it that's
a conspiracy so my my point is that's
why I have my air always at 76 inside
because I know secretly that's the right
because if people say oh if you say what
is the best temperature outside a lot of
people will be like well definitely not
room temperature probably more I know
why why because they're outside there's
breezes foreign playing a guitar and
like shade and like elements you know so
it's not just this stagnant 76. indoors
it's a stagnant 76 and a stagnant 76
doesn't feel very good yeah I don't know
I think that it should be 76 degrees
always no matter what I'm holding your
doggy Okay we're doing a show you know
Adam Sandler um
you know what I don't like how everyone
always says Adam Sandler he dresses so
dope and that's the fit and he just
wears basketball shorts all the time who
says that it's on like people say Adam's
on her dress as well yeah like like he's
like yeah this is the level I want to be
at and it's like no I don't want to be
that lover I mean I know he's so rich
and he's just wearing basketball shorts
because who gives a [ __ ] yeah but always
I want to be wearing pants yeah I never
want to be wearing shorts wearing shorts
is my the very last straw it's for me
speaking of uh you know outfits your
outfit on Halloween was really great oh
yeah yeah you were an American Cowboy I
was American I was the American Cowboy
so I made up a character uh we can get a
pick up there uh uh boat for you guys
but I was basically I had American
cowboy hat with red white and blue and I
had an American jacket with red white
and blue stitched into it and I was
wearing a sheriff's badge so you know
the priests yeah so okay so you're the
American Cowboy and also you you upheld
the law over yeah and you were
trick-or-treating and Calvin I was
basically the sheriff and so therefore
freeze basically
um you were and uh also Calvin was a
purple people eater and you were there
and you were helping him
trick-or-treating it was really cute oh
dude he was so cute huh yeah he's so
focused he did it like it's his job yeah
he was going to trick-or-treat like it
was his job and then afterwards and he
wasn't really saying much and then
afterwards just talking so much it's
because he had 7 000 grams of sugar
though yeah but he was saying it before
he even ate it he was like I got so many
candies I got so many K on the drive
home I got so many candies and we were
like okay okay I got so many candies I
mean it was unbelievable and he got like
25 candies I mean I guess that's a lot
but to him it's a lot too I remember
dude I remember looking at his Hall the
other day and I was like
that ain't [ __ ] yeah my haul's back in
the day [ __ ] 70 pieces are bust 70
pieces or get out of my [ __ ] way yeah
I was coming up on 125 pieces just like
pouring it out [ __ ] mom and dad
downstairs being like stop the other
rocket because there was so much [ __ ]
candy on the floor in their ceiling
we're brothers I would have been there
but um yeah speaking of outfits though I
did not like we just were talking about
this I don't like Heidi klum's outfit as
the worm and you liked it yes you said
it was good and I want you to expound on
that what is good about it what's good
about it is that it's cool
to look at it it's cool to look at it
okay that's the reason I liked it make a
picture I'll look at it but but I didn't
see her walk around and that seems like
it might tip this special the other way
like did she she should have just rolled
around wow so here's the thing I don't
like about that guy it's like she's
outdone herself she keeps out doing
herself she's gonna have to what is she
gonna be then you know what I mean she
next year she's got it can't be as good
so I don't like it because also it's
it's so in the way dude these costumes
that are bigger than you are make the
costume how big you are right it's like
you're going to a party people are
[ __ ] bumping into her tripping and
[ __ ] and like are you in line like in
the bathroom she can't get in because
it's too tall yeah and then what if she
has to go to the bathroom I don't know
she must have had a bag on her yeah
maybe she put in a catheter for the
night yeah yeah colostomy bag disgusting
[ __ ] [ __ ] and pissing it oh my God
yeah ew dude Heidi Klum you're gross
yeah you shouldn't pissed in your
costume so you were an American Cowboy
she was a worm I was a Dracula and
Calvin was a purple people eater and
Kristen was a witch
um and uh that's it we were that's what
we had yeah yeah
apparently I was [ __ ] pissed though
because last year nobody came by my
house so I didn't get candy oh right and
this year people came by my house really
and the reason I didn't get candies
because they didn't come the year before
I was like I'm a way up on a hill
they're not gonna combine yeah I got
[ __ ] cold busted dude twice but just
turn all your lights out I did I froze
no I mean but keep your so oh so they
were were your lights were out no the
lights are on oh yeah turn the lights
out I froze all right you don't have to
actually freeze I don't want to make my
floorboards are creaky so I just went
okay but you can do basically just have
your lights out and then just but then
I'm home in the dark and it's [ __ ]
sucks you know it's like hiding from two
people in your American Cowboy outfit I
will not be held hostage by my fears
okay well this uh uh okay so I'm gonna
be in Boston coming up in on a November
12th the first show sold out the second
show where there are still tickets left
I got Lakeland Florida and uh what
another Florida
uh Lakeland another Florida you know
Jacksonville and then I've got uh San
Diego and the New York New York February
18th we added a show at the Beacon
Theater uh the first one is almost sold
out and then I'll be at the Chicago
theater so uh Portland and Seattle
Seattle's almost done so go to
chrisley.com and get tickets and uh
that's what's up
but what so did you want to go in right
into it
uh sure anything else about Halloween do
you like Halloween
I don't uh I like how we know that I'm a
dad uh because this was the first time
that um Calvin was
uh
uh aware like a where aware yeah right
right yeah like he saw a big skeleton he
was just like a big skeleton and then I
was like you want to go get more candy
and he says yes and he runs up there so
he got a lot of candies he was how did
he know he wanted to be a purple people
he said
um he said that he he likes the song so
our friend played this song Purple
People Eater I actually don't know no no
no Kristen played Purple People Eater
okay that stupid song from the 1940s you
know and uh he was playing it and then
he liked it and then we said we wanted
for Halloween and he said people leader
and we were like nobody has a purple
people eater yeah how do you even know
so she made it Christian's crafty and
she made it of course she did and she
was and he was so basically we got the
boo character from Monsters Inc which is
purple it's the only purple monster
because I don't have a purple people
eater thing yeah you know a costume and
so she got the boo outfit and then she
took one of the eyes off because it's
one eye and then got a horn put it on
and then you know change the costume a
little bit and people whenever someone
was like hey it's boo I would get
secretly pissed off yeah you should get
because it's good people eater and if
you knew boo-boo has two eyes and no
horns so you should ask if you don't if
you don't know what it is you asked
right well they thought they knew but
they were just dead wronged yeah they
were dead wrong and they almost ruined
the entire uh night and I obviously
condone Kyle's costume because it's all
purple and I'm all purple all the time
but oh hey June has a [ __ ] purple
color on baby baby
and Booyah and so also uh Calvin was uh
would they say oh boo and then he
thought people are saying boo because of
Halloween and then he kept drawing on
the drive back he gave
she said boo she said boo so it all kind
of worked out really right because it
did work out yeah
um all right let's go into Lifeline in
the news here we go oh
Kanye West continues to self-immolate by
mentioning bad dealings with people he
can't talk about and then mentions
Jewish people which has led to Gap
Balenciaga and Adidas to cut ties with
them advice for kind of yeah here's my
advice for Kanye shut the [ __ ] up dude
you can't open your mouth without saying
something super shitty and [ __ ]
offensive like shut the [ __ ] up dude
right you can't dig yourself out you've
said every possible [ __ ] shitty
stereotype about Jews out loud in front
of microphones and in front of cameras
shut the [ __ ] up what I don't understand
is like is he does he feel like he's on
a crusade like why doesn't he just stop
talking I know like why do you have to
talk this is the thing about hate it's
so weird because you first of all I
think he's he's mentally not well but
like why don't you just not talk about
that like you don't have to talk about
all the things all the time pick other
things to talk about even if you do hate
Jews or whatever the [ __ ] shut up don't
talk about it shut up about it talk
about other things like your music or
your [ __ ] fashion they wanna you know
what I mean it's like that's the thing I
don't get so my advice for Kanye is
spend time thinking about other things
besides Jews yeah nip it in the butt
yeah boy he can't do that now it's a
full-bloom right right right right right
now and apparently he has apologized and
stuff and done stuff like that but the
media is not covering it which sucks
he's [ __ ] the media but [ __ ] but [ __ ]
him but he'll apologize and be like but
that's because like he's one of the 12
tribes of Judah he says I'm not Jewish
I'm Jew
uh and he's like trying to Circle
encircle the whole thing by saying how
can I be anti-semitic when I'm black and
that means I'm a Jew
hey man that's not what it means
everything you say is not true also
about that how about that everything he
says is not right also if he's a Jew
then like he's talking about how he
doesn't like Jews I know shut up yeah
you're then you're just you're
contradicting yourself because he's
saying they've persecuted him but he
also he's part of it
say yeah think about other things and I
love how he says it like it's some kind
of [ __ ] new idea that nobody knows
about hey man this is the same [ __ ]
dumbass conspiracy theory since 2000
years ago yeah yeah and we stopped and
we try we should have stopped it
basically a long time ago but also after
the 40s definitely should have stopped
because we saw what happened so yeah
okay yeah seriously Kanye
next shut the [ __ ] up
oh here we go another shot I don't know
I pretty much know nothing about him
except he's pro-life so here's a big
shut the [ __ ] up okay read this and then
okay so Herschel Walker has an extremely
pro-life stance on abortion despite
having paid for several of them in his
past relationships what's the advice for
Herschel okay here's the advice
rehearsal be real yeah I know just be
honest man just say you can say I you
even if you want to say I used to be and
I've been saved since like just be
[ __ ] real be honest dude several
women have come forth and like they got
receipts receipts texts and literal
receipts in of payment for abortions yes
and he's saying I didn't do it yes yeah
and even his his other children of which
he's got like children from like seven
or eight different women uh these
children that he acknowledges are his
even those children are like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like you've you've come
I think he's accused of committing
sexual assault as well like crazy [ __ ]
he claims to have been diagnosed with
multiple personality disorder and cured
it himself oh wow okay so don't vote for
him yeah but he's dude he's running neck
and neck with [ __ ] Raphael Warnock
and which is insane it just goes to show
up entrench people off the candidate
doesn't matter the party matters that's
it right right right which is so stupid
wait that's so [ __ ] crazy that uh
also you know what I had a poster of him
when I was in my when I was a kid dude
he was the [ __ ] he was like the mo it
looks such an insane athlete he was so
good uh but you know a lot of people
just like [ __ ] actors just like
politicians athletes they're [ __ ]
they're Heroes when you don't know
anything about him then they're [ __ ]
absolutely idiot [ __ ] when you learn
a few times he has concussions for sure
so what what's the deal with does he say
that so he says I didn't that didn't
happen and people are just like okay you
think if he said it did happen and I've
changed and I think that the error in my
ways you think he would he'll probably
[ __ ] take a dip no dude that's the
whole Christian thing if he made it I
mean he's an outwardly Christian that's
the whole Christian scene where born
Sinners we're born [ __ ] terrible in
the eyes of God and all we can do is ask
for ask for uh acceptance and then admit
that word [ __ ] just these pieces of
[ __ ] you know
uh John 6 14. we are all admit that we
are pieces of [ __ ] yeah I mean basically
that's the whole Bible admit you're a
piece of [ __ ] admit you're a piece of
[ __ ] step your piece of [ __ ] except one
Exodus step one meet your piece of [ __ ]
yeah more or less and he won't admit it
the piece of [ __ ] Adam met the piece of
[ __ ] eaten I mean
in the piece of [ __ ] garden and took a
piece of [ __ ] bite out of an apple
um snake came up said don't do it all
right let's do it all right next well
the advice for him is stop yeah be real
stop poking be without a hat on but also
beyond that be real be honest yeah it's
a whole Christian way dude what the [ __ ]
I want it well I mean look [ __ ] it it's
no uh he was a football player in the
80s he was definitely sporting with no
hat on I mean without so we know even
more than the receipts yeah we know fact
even football player in the 80s support
with no hat on so absolutely you should
have more kids also he he also [ __ ]
is like has like impersonated cops he's
done like a ton of illegal [ __ ] what
he's he's he's of course he has football
player domestic abuse like everything
football player in the 80s there you go
yeah that's the way the department no
hat on and pretending you're a cop there
was like a checklist for football
players in the 80s yeah put on this
badge okay and go around and try to
rescue all right great thanks Joe
Montana hit her and then supporting her
with no hat on okay great okay Jerry
Rice your next okay here we go
hey Chris hey Matt it's Trista from
Calgary Alberta just wanted to ask
how would you react when a girl makes
the first move I'm sure both of you have
had experience in that oh he's three
years old so I'm pretty young and
actually this is kind of the first year
that of my life that I've felt it
happening and noticed it
um because you're so sexy and every time
I do notice it I get flattered and all
but I freeze up I feel like maybe I'm
still supposed to put in a bunch of
effort or I don't know this girl so I
have to really try
but uh I don't really know what to do I
get stunned practically because it just
seems awkward it seems different
and I know it shouldn't be and I really
wish that I had a little bit of a
voice in my head telling me just to go
for it
stick with what's going on and stick
with the situation but I always kind of
mess it up and run away or or push them
away so if you guys have any advice
about that that'd be awesome to hear
thanks I got some great advice for that
what stop running away when a girl tries
to kiss you hey what's your name nobody
gonna try to kiss him he said first move
we don't know if that means to kiss or
if it's flirting okay just like first
step one just [ __ ] relax like he
sounds like such a spaz I always run
away or pushing her away
like relax dude yeah like the most
relaxed possible the girl likes you you
like the girl all she's doing is showing
you signs that she likes you this is a
good thing this is a good thing take a
deep breath of this to happen although I
will say it does kind of throw me off
like if you know I don't know it's
different uh it's different honestly
being uh well okay look I don't like
being famous is different because
obviously it happens all the time but
like but like to be somebody that's just
at a power party and a girl starts
hitting on you like that to me that's
like uh is she just am I gonna wind up
dead is this a spy this is so weird yeah
it's so weird not to me probably because
it's happened to me so many times okay
if you're at a party and you're not on
you know people know who you are if
you're at a party and this isn't what
you do you're just some guy at a party
and some girl comes up to you and says
hey what's up wow nice sweater you look
great what's your thing we should get
you I should get your number
all the middays work for you yeah
you don't think huh
I don't know I don't think anything bad
I think oh that was great this saved me
so much work right but it's definitely
odd
but it stands out to me in a good way
just turn it turn your perspective dude
yeah it's like eliminating so much so
many like things Hoops you might have to
jump through she's being clear she's
being forward this is what we want
people to be yeah I think but yeah I
guess so I've heard people talk about
how like
they as the men like to be the one
leading you away but like [ __ ] give
that up and if that is the thing that
you feel then just when when a girl says
hi how you doing what are you doing here
and then once you ask for your number
and then she's like we should go out
sometime you just go like this
no no no no no no sweetheart that's not
how this works right
[Laughter]
I'll take it from here
I'll take it from here Dame nice scams
and walk away
yeah uh I just think you need to take a
deep breath man it sounds like you panic
when a girl shows interest in you uh but
speaking from vast experience
yeah you know let it happen how many
times have you been hit on
I can't count yeah many many times
period though that's what he means
um yeah so happens to be all the time
too so it's fine not happy to be more
okay well so that's all good I don't
know
yeah next that's it for this guys this
one happens to me all good hey man Chris
Matt you're hot hit me up what did I
tell you right on cue
um I need some advice I've been dating
this guy for about six months he's a
Private Pilot which is cool I guess but
it's not what I like about him
um it's now six months in and it's still
the only thing he talks about uh it's
always like a blue Jeff Foxworthy I flew
um Rod Stewart this is how propellers
work engines whatever I don't care
that's Washington I try to change the
subjects and he has this incredible
ability to just turn it right back into
easy piloting flying [ __ ]
um I've made it really obvious that it's
annoying to me he's not getting the
hints at this point do I just tell him
to shut the [ __ ] up I don't want to be
an [ __ ]
like do I do the spin move out of there
like it's really really annoying and
I don't know what to do so help
that sounds bad yeah it is a good one
what do you what do you uh have to say
here's the thing people don't this guy's
got a problem I used to think people
like me because I'm a comedian but like
that's not why people like me people
like you because you're you you know and
they don't like you because you're you
and if she likes you it's because you're
you this is the thing I wish we had him
on for the advice right yeah but like
what she's got to do is just be like yo
I don't give a f I like you because
you're you I don't care how high up you
are I don't give a [ __ ] how close to the
cloud you are I don't care that you're
in a metal tube 30 000 feet in the sky I
only care you're you and right now the
you you're being is braggadocious about
something that I don't even like you
because of yeah right now yes I got that
one I nailed it right now you are being
hella [ __ ] annoying yeah hella hella
[ __ ] annoying dude she looks like she
was from North North they're in
California no she's definitely not she's
from Chicago or Philadelphia oh okay
well so sorry look sorry sorry I ever
said something yeah uh but um yeah I
don't uh
yeah it's I don't I don't know I I think
it's so annoying when people talk about
what they do all the time I mean you see
you see it happen with with dad because
he's like a producer and a director
right and then people will who are
actors they just want to talk business
with them and you know Dad's like I
would just rather talk about the Dodgers
he doesn't want to talk about work ever
and that's how I feel too yeah I mean I
kind of like talking about comedy
sometimes but I I just mostly like
joking around the thing for me is that I
think and talk enough about movies about
what I do enough if if I have the option
to talk to somebody about movies or
something else almost always I'll choose
something else so I'm the exact opposite
of this guy why does he want to talk
about all the people he's how many times
can he bring up that he flew Rod Stewart
around right well he's probably insecure
about how he he wants her to like him
because of the [ __ ] famous people
that he cards around but also that's
like bragging about being online next to
[ __ ] Paul Giamatti which I was
for tacos in Santa Barbara thank you oh
really I do like that about you
I think that what uh yeah basically all
you do is [ __ ] you're a chauffeur in
the sky yeah dude exactly yeah it's not
good yeah oh it's like you're an Uber
driver Uber driver that happened to pick
up Rod Stewart yeah he cares born who
cares okay so I better have better [ __ ]
going on about you but we're again we're
veering into giving advice to the guy
for you I think I mean maybe bring it up
what's the best way to bring that up be
like hey man like you talk about flying
a lot uh that's cool I think it's
awesome you're a pilot but I also don't
that's not what I like about you yeah
you talk about it a lot and I wonder why
if you're trying to impress me but
what's the tone to take with that
because you don't want to get him like
just say how I said it that's so like
that's that's
I don't know that's too I'm aggressive
yeah accusatory or something yeah
Christian says I have a tone okay well I
don't okay okay well you do but I think
if you come at it yeah I guess if you
come at it like from a question
perspective like why do you do do you
think I like don't like you already I do
like you don't have to constantly tell
me about this stuff try to impress me
I'm already impressed by who you are
yeah you could also say whenever he
starts bringing up somebody like I I
flew around Jeff foxworld to be like oh
[ __ ] and then get your pad out and then
write down and he says what you're doing
well I keep track on uh who you uh fly
around because I think it's so [ __ ]
awesome right right I think he'll get to
him right or you could do the same thing
yeah take a pad out write something down
and he says what are you running and she
can say I just like to make lists of the
most [ __ ] boring dumb things I've
ever been told yeah and that is
absolutely near the top yeah you say
that too yeah yeah which would which
would definitely get him that's good
that's good that's good both of those
are good that might even be better that
would definitely get a stop sooner yeah
you wouldn't have thought about it if I
did what I did but it's fine all right
so let's go to the next one but uh yeah
that's a tough that's tough but it maybe
I don't know but maybe maybe the sex is
good I have a dog on my lap
Madison Matt big fan of the Pod my
question for y'all today is um I love
going to the gym it's my thing I've been
going for years now and I lately can't
seem to get through a workout without
somebody trying to talk to me she's bad
or asking me out what are we going to do
I feel like I have bother me written on
my forehead and I just
don't understand what's happening lately
it makes me really uncomfortable because
I'm generally a really shy person and I
don't like
um so much attention and I also feel
really bad rejecting people because I
know it takes a lot of courage to ask
somebody out so I guess my question is
how do I reject someone nicely and also
maybe how do I make myself less
approachable is that weird I don't yeah
no no it's not weird yeah but you know
what my advice says don't be so bad okay
how did she do how does she like lower
her Badness well first of all I mean I
hate you know people are always like
well you should wear whatever you want
[ __ ] these dudes but like if you're
working out some of these outfits that
these
these women who wear at the gym yeah
they accentuate the Badness right but I
mean they have they have [ __ ] like uh
uh like Lululemon shits that like curve
under the under the butt right and like
it makes it look like it's like and
that's like okay if you're trying to
[ __ ] make people not talk to you
don't accentuate them well let's assume
she's not doing that because I'm just
saying so let's let's start with that if
you are doing that don't accentuate the
Badness wear a [ __ ] you know it's
really annoying here's what I think you
could wear different [ __ ] but if you
want it okay go go ahead but you're at
the gym how come most guys I know are
like oh my God I when I say something
like the worst place to hit on a woman
is at the gym that is very true so why
does every guy agree with me and yet
every woman has this can play who the
[ __ ] are these guys that don't know this
I'll tell you why because I do know this
but they also are at the gym and the
girls go to the gym and they're there
all the time and they see them all the
time so in a guy's head they're like oh
I've seen her a bunch are you using that
oh cool oh my by the way this and that
you're gonna [ __ ] end up talking and
flirting just because you're looking bad
you feel bad you're a dude and you feel
bad because you're putting up two plates
right so you feel bad and you think well
this is the baddest I've been I'm the
baddest I am at the gym and this chick's
got the [ __ ] that Scoops her under right
and it the Lululemon shits that keep her
the the [ __ ] Apple up and nice and so
he's like she's bad I'm bad I'm being
bad we're both bad Michael Jordan
Michael Jackson Michael Jackson hey we
see the I'm bad you ain't nothing and we
see each other all the time and so it's
like let's just [ __ ] see what's up
dude are you using that nice bam oh you
come here a lot oh bam if you're there
at the gym if you're there at the gym
and I'm there at the gym I don't give a
[ __ ] because I'm not attracted to you
but if you're attracted to Badness like
a lot of these dudes and a lot of the
dudes that work out I hate to say it and
this is going to come across a Prejudice
but they're Persian and you know
Persians when they see chicks I have to
say something though so the the guys
that are doing it Are Persian and the
guy I'm not I don't talk to many Persian
guys but you're saying they're my
favorite people are Persians so I guess
Sam a good friend of ours is Persian but
that might be the only one that I speak
to Sam at the gym Sim doesn't go to the
gym but if he went to the gym he
couldn't help himself he's like hey hey
what's up you're going to be using that
oh see this is a thing I don't know yeah
uh because I don't know many person man
that must be why all the men who agree
with me yeah
I think that uh you know what you can do
is first of all
what's this earphone
airpods okay you're fine they might not
come up
so don't accentuate the battle oh you're
saying she should wear them and then you
can pretend you don't hear anything yeah
here's what will be great here's what
would be great you don't have to come
across as being a dick a dick but you
guys go hey what's up yeah and you let
him do the whole thing and go like this
what yeah the state of what rude like
implying that you definitely don't want
even to take them out and be out of
breath right
what right yeah oh never mind right
you're still being a person even though
I said that I mean Persian they hit on a
lot first of all I think
even if you're wearing lululelemons that
is my brother would say shape your Apple
in the right make the apple right make
it look like it's in the back of your
back uh you could wear whatever you want
but just do the headphones thing yeah
and then it'll it'll it'll be like she
you know just how she wipes her ass with
the little image what's that because the
ass is so high up oh oh oh oh God that's
disgusting okay something about people
wiping their ass in general you know
what I mean there's nothing more
disgusting than wiping an ass you're
like oh oh you have bad breath but like
no I farted because it came out here all
right okay okay why is it up here I
farted I'm wearing a little lemon why is
it up here yeah yeah like like farts
only smell down by that
um yeah so don't be so bad number one
that's your own problem go go to your
mom and be like Mom what the [ __ ] yeah
you made me so bad yeah I'm at the gym I
can't get these Persians away right
right right
God damn it I'm going to the bathroom
yeah
you know Mom why'd you have to make me
so bad I put on Lululemon's and it's
crazy dude it's
dude it's a [ __ ] LA Fitness
right I mean I guess yeah yeah just do
the headphones thing you're all good hey
guys I want to take a break and talk to
you about surf Shark look sure surf
shark is a VPN which keeps your online
activity private but there are a bunch
of reasons to have a VPN and it's
honestly one of those things that's just
growing and growing it's better it's
it's cooler and cooler to have it and
it's uh more and more necessary uh you
can access your bank safely even on
public Wi-Fi stuff like this get the
best deals with online shopping it uh
they don't let websites show you prices
based on your location or device turn on
your surf shark VPN and get the best
deals When shopping online or buying
your next flight ticket uh I actually
was in London
um and couldn't sign into my HBO account
went and I used surf shark because you
know they don't let you do it through
the
um different countries went through my
surf shark and guess what
I'm watching House of dragons right
that's what happens so I uh I use surf
shark myself to watch blacked out
baseball games that I want to see oh
it's great for sports
yes exactly that they don't show
necessarily uh where you are staying yes
exactly uh in your life in your state uh
one subscription unlimited devices yes
you could even share one account with
all your friends and pay less than a
piece of gum for a more secure and
private online life it's just worth it
man it's one of those things everybody's
gonna have soon you should you have to
have this you should have this the link
is in the description below to get 83
off and three extra months for free
that's surf shark so go in the
description below and get the link
and I've got a question about career
mentality so I work for a Fortune 500
company and dragon we are known to not
necessarily pay as well as some of the
other companies in our industry right
and don't get me wrong I am a 26 year
old homeowner and I do very well for
myself
I don't necessarily feel like I'm
getting compensated for the value that
they say I am putting forward yeah okay
um you know they've given me an
exceptional performance rating over the
past two years and I have gotten pay
bumps but
I could be making more at another
company so how do I navigate that kind
of conversation with my manager or
continue to put forth that 110 effort if
I don't feel like I'm being compensated
for the the value that they say I'm
putting forth and you know the work that
I'm doing
um I really appreciate the podcast and
everything that you guys do so any
advice would help thank you thanks bro
yeah thanks I think there's just a way
to say it real plain without sounding
like you like it's the it's interesting
I feel like there's a tone of voice
thing where you can sound like you're
asking for something because you think
you deserve it I don't have a tone but
yeah and you and you're asking for
something because you you like want to
open a conversation and I think if you
do the latter even if you do feel the
first way you will get
as long as you're not like a pushover
you will get you're more likely to get
what you want yeah you know especially
if you start comparing like what other
places pay for the same kind of work
it's like you don't want you don't want
to say pay me more or else I'm gonna go
somewhere else but you can be like you
know I've noticed just in my years here
like uh other companies I think they pay
more like and I'm just trying to get a
sense of like what the long-term plan is
because I'd like to be here for a long
time yeah what's the upward Mobility
like for me because I really want to
like move up and up and up at this
company yes okay but let's not forget
when I went yes on the first one I had
good advice so okay
um but yeah I don't know he could be you
know I think the advice the the the tone
you use is that like look I'm kind of
stuck between a rock and a hard place
here because if I don't say anything
then I don't get you know the money and
if don't say it this way but like but if
I if I it's like I know how much I could
be making with other companies and like
I love to work hard for you guys and
it's just like I don't I don't want to
leave I love this company but also uh I
wanna I wanna be able to make sure that
I can live the best life I can
monetarily and so
I'd love to open up a dialogue about how
possibly like if there's something I
could be doing or or something I'm not
doing that you think that maybe I could
[ __ ] I could start making some more
money or something like that
yeah I think what I said well I mean I
pretty much said what you did but I
think what I said is a little bit better
right so rewind it depends on what the
company rewind this go back to exactly
what I said if it's a weed company do
how I did it okay yeah sure um yeah uh
that's that's uh weird that they try
they're just trying to I don't know man
they're just trying to take advantage of
you but here's the thing and here's
really what what's deeper in three two
one you can't uh expect people to do
anything but take advantage of you
and you cannot be surprised and you
certainly cannot take it personally when
they do it takes it everybody would take
advantage of dude people take advantage
of their [ __ ] mom if I meant 10 more
Grand a year you know like people will
take advantage of [ __ ] anyone under
any circumstance if they think they'll
benefit themselves don't take it
personally though because guess what
you'd probably do the same
so just don't be don't take anything
personal because if you do that'll come
out in the way your voice sounds when
you approach this [ __ ] yeah so just
[ __ ] recognize that this is not
personal this is just somebody trying to
take advantage of somebody else by
paying them not up to Snuff in terms of
what people at that position usually get
yeah you don't want to give away your
money they don't want to give away their
money yeah exactly yeah yeah okay cool
next one
hey Matt and Chris Daniel from Cleveland
Ohio here
um I was raised Mennonite and as a
Mennonite you're not allowed to wear
jewelry but I have left them in the
nights a while back now and I do enjoy
wearing jewelry but only if it means
something I don't like wearing jewelry
if it doesn't mean anything I feel like
a douchebag and I think subtlety is sexy
it's the sexiest thing okay
um so how much jewelry should guys wear
and should you wear jewelry as a guy if
it really doesn't mean anything if it's
just for decoration
um second question is what's a cool
thing to pass down to uh you know my son
I have a seven-year-old son what's it
the cool thing to pass down to him like
a watch or something like that obviously
I'm not getting an inheritance from my
dad
that's a deeper so I want to pass
something down to my son when he gets
married or graduates College something
like that
so yeah let me know what you think
um side note I laid carpet at hilarities
comedy club in Cleveland so oh that's
for you Chris that's cool
I love that club hilarities in Cleveland
um uh he doesn't wear Julie but
investing to pass down I think is a
watch because it doesn't lose its
investment
doesn't lose his value it doesn't lose
his value yeah it increases in value it
can yeah really I don't wear watches I
hate the way they feel my wrist uh well
but I've never really given one a shot I
know people say like keep it on for a
couple
yeah why do I do that if you don't want
yeah exactly
um yeah that that's a good thing to do
there are a lot of do how much what do
you what do you got change I've got this
this this and I have a chastity belathon
would uh Calvin give a [ __ ] about any of
that stuff that's so bad when I get a
boner well not now because well now yeah
because it's fun he would hold it you
know this he would love to take and whip
it around but I mean when he's an adult
well I don't know I mean he would it's
you know was there anything you think
about that you would one day hand down
to him
yeah this
yeah I would I would hand down this
until
what is it
the same Christopher I've had forever
how long this is actually brand new but
this one's like
since I was a teenager it's like 18
maybe oh wow
um yeah it's cool to pass stuff down um
you know that's a saint helps with your
travel right I mean this is yeah this
yeah you know if you want to if you
believe in that stuff which is cool what
is it gonna keep me safe or something
yeah yeah whatever it is I mean so
[ __ ] dismissive St Christopher is
keep us safe travel yeah yeah keep us
safe okay Keep Us Safe Keep Us Safe at
while we travel yeah his thing though is
three words just keep us safe oh it is
okay cool I think it I think it was uh
make America great again but no I don't
think so someone else
um he so yeah I I you know he doesn't
wear I mean subtlety is the most sexy
thing he said I personally me I think
it's [ __ ] long legs and tits but yeah
I think I think it's like um
a beautiful face and like heavy duty
attraction that it you know gives me
bars subtlety doesn't just like make my
penis erect in a vacuum I don't know man
you see how subtle that was yeah I mean
you ever see the movie uh what's that
movie that's real subtle I don't know oh
wow whatever yeah
do the joke at home what's that movie
um yeah uh I I
um yeah I think that
subtlety is you know it's like you I get
what he's saying he doesn't want to be
so hey look at me ostentatious yeah he
wants to be comfortable in his own skin
that is sexy right yeah that is sexy
yeah but also he likes a little bit of
jewelry but also the reason why he likes
probably a little bit of jewelry is
because his parents said you can't wear
jewelry so let's not let them get all in
your [ __ ] you know main frame and
absolutely take over and over compensate
because let's not do that right right
right yeah okay uh yeah I just think
[ __ ] ah how do you answer this thing
is cool it's like you you want to get
jewelry just to pass it down like I'm
confused it has to mean something you're
you're right in saying it should mean
something but if it doesn't mean
anything you can't buy it and you can't
buy it it's like looking for love you
can't look for it it just hits you over
the side yeah when it happens yeah so if
you see a thing that you like cool but
also you're gonna have to wear it for a
long time you can't just give your son
something because oh hey I found this
necklace and I wore it for a week and
then here I'm passing it on to you I
know what should happen Okay what let's
get his wife huh tell her buy him a
piece of jewelry so then it'll have
inherent meaning and then he'll have
something to pass on to uh uh his son
right yeah so hey that guy's wife I know
you're watching buy him some [ __ ] also
that's his son seven
so you don't need to pass anything down
to him for the next 40 years but you
wanted to have some weight on it you
want to have some years
like you said you don't want to be just
some necklace he's wearing for a week
you know well right but if he just buys
himself a necklace and wears it for 40
years then let's get some meaning yeah I
guess right I bought this after I I get
the guys from Lifeline gave me advice no
but here's the thing 40 years later this
is why it's a puzzle he doesn't want to
buy something that feels arbitrary he
wants it to have meaning to begin with
okay get your wife or your girl whoever
I don't know if he's married or not but
uh leave notes around the house that
hint at what you want yeah but don't say
it because if you say it it'll lose it
to me just walk up to your wife and be
like huh it'd be crazy to have something
to pass on to my son wants that jewelry
exactly yeah I know I met a night but it
doesn't matter I I don't remember the
thing about being a Mennonite is you
know we don't believe in jewelry but me
I'm not a Mennonite anymore and I'm very
happy my son is in a minute anymore and
I feel like there's maybe a good way to
symbolize that yeah yeah vis-a-vis
jewelry I mean I don't know though I
don't know better hurry up though
because like um you know I need to start
wearing something to make it mean
something yeah yeah that's crazy all
right cool all right next one
hey Chris and Matt love your podcast I'm
a huge fan me and my boyfriend both are
um so I have a quick question it might
be a silly question Southern but my
boyfriend does not like when I bring up
my exes their names or anything about
them whatsoever good don't know yeah I
know that's probably normal to dislike
that but
he gets really mad if I ever bring up a
name good don't next shut up so my
question is is he going a little
overboard or like can I like I can't
even share my life experiences with him
good don't know from my past because the
majority of my past experiences involve
accents and like I want to be able to
share things with him yeah
um nope so just let me know if I'm being
too
because I want to respect him and stuff
but oh just let me know
um I'm Ali I'm from South Carolina my
girlfriend's Philip and we love your
podcast uh we love Lifeline we love
congratulations and we were gonna come
see you guys uh or see you Chris but
we're gonna hopefully get to it next
time thanks
um very cool uh you're already trying
not to say anything that's all you can
do if you [ __ ] mess up every once in
a while
he should understand you're making a
serious effort 100 you're trying to
compromise he should meet you [ __ ]
halfway come on man yeah she's sweet and
and and and and he's doing too much it
sounds like like dude it's gonna happen
I don't like hearing about x's and [ __ ]
yeah I never really cared yeah me either
but like um I I don't I mean I don't you
know what I mean
the thing about action you know what for
me I didn't care about if it was like
relationships where you loved somebody
and like you actually gained experience
from it but like if I wanna like hearing
about exit like yeah I met this guy at
[ __ ] you know moose mcgillicuddies
and just sucked him up in an Alleyway
behind a dumpster where they [ __ ]
shot uh Mulholland Drive I don't wanna I
mean I don't want to hear that [ __ ] so
it depends what you're saying it depends
what you're saying if you're like well
you know my you remember Dave Eve we
went out for three years and I learned a
lot through that that's fine but if
she's like you know it's funny man at
one time at Waffle House you know I met
a waiter and he was just so hot I waited
till he got off and then I made sure I
got him off in the back of my Chevelle I
sucked them up good he hit the back of
my throat and it was nuts well why are
you getting so mad Phillip
it's not like he didn't eat my [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude he wasn't just using me
he lit me up real nice outside the
[ __ ] Cracker Barrel at 3pm
Okay so
so it's like
I mean it depends on what you're saying
because that literally if we talk to
Philip he was like well I just wish you
know okay well I think it's I'm assuming
it's sort of like a given that that's
not what she's doing she's talking about
her life experiences yeah and how she
was with someone at the time the story
has to include that person yeah but at
the same at the same time it doesn't
really have to include that one time I
met a dude outside of video shagging I I
sat on a sybian for him for nine hours
never saw him again
got a bought a VCR sat on a sybian for
nine hours
it's it's sweet of you and you're going
above and beyond to try to not mention
any of your exes he needs to [ __ ] cut
you some slack for that in the first
place he just Googled sibia and that's
why he's laughing
is that right no he knows what a [ __ ] is
he's an adult man okay
all right well if you don't know what a
sybian is Google it everybody knows what
obsidian is you sit on it all right I'll
give you a hint you said on it and it
vibrates all right but why by the way
sybians are weird I'll just get a dildo
no the sybian is like yeah but it's like
such a [ __ ] cumbersome device you
know you have to put in a basement and
[ __ ]
sybians are like uh what like I feel
like gymnasts their bar like it's so
space it's like you have to go somewhere
else to get on a sybian yeah there's a
[ __ ] Sybian uh it's like batting
cages
[Laughter]
uh let me get yeah let me get an hour
[Laughter]
what speed in cage is just oh yeah oh
yeah waiting like this
[Laughter]
Phillips why we have to come here it
reminds me of [ __ ] Gary
I only got 15 minutes
um hold the picture of Gary in front of
me sybians look like they're not fun do
you know what I'm saying yeah
[ __ ] violent and really shake you up
like after you get off a simian you're
like still shaking you know yeah yeah oh
but that you're too excited about that
yeah I watched those videos one time and
then I was like man it's too much that's
what I'm saying so I'm saying
it's just weird to be like a [ __ ]
like if you want really like exploring
your body is fine and and it's fine to
bring a few things but like the second
you got and you need help bringing
something in to explore your body yeah
it's like too much yeah it's like it's
like it's like [ __ ] hang gliding like
just get in a [ __ ] plane or or bungee
jump
you know what I mean okay hang gliding
you got to learn kind of how to do it
and [ __ ] and then that first time you do
it you gotta run off the cliff and just
kind of hope for the best you know
that's so scary the first time yeah
you're like here we go okay I hope it
works
and then somebody's like some people are
like here we go I hope it works how it
works
you know what I mean
like literally that's that happened you
practice so much for hang gliding and
then you're just like here we go here we
go here we go
you know and you die you spend what
months [ __ ] practicing
that's basically what a sybian is he
said you don't die on the city no you
probably there have been sibians how
many sibian deaths do you think there's
been ever in history even if there's one
I had more than one because if there's
one that would be more than one but that
would be so shitty if you were known as
the [ __ ] Sybian dad I bet there's six
Sybian related deaths in history oh I
think I say a year no just ever all
right well fine one more
all right this guy sent in three
separate videos okay well that's not
except back to back oh okay wow wow okay
so be patient here we go what's going on
Chris I'm Matt sorry I gotta talk really
fast but you guys won't let me post more
than a minute and I have a lot of [ __ ]
that I gotta talk about I really need
help for one I work in my family boat
yard last month I got completely set on
fire head to toe that's why I'm wearing
this thing I have UV protective Shields
even on a cloudy day I have to wear it
also I get sunburned I have a chance of
melanoma my face will start blistering
my skin will get different color and
I'll never come back to the right color
that it's [ __ ] horrible everything
sucks two I don't want to work here to
begin with I don't like mechanics I get
paid less than minimum wage the only
reason that I'm here is because it's a
family business I'm gonna own it one day
and also I'm [ __ ] my dad needs my
help he has Ms he can't really walk that
well and he needs me to be a pair of
legs to help him walk around and get
stuff three my girlfriend of four years
that I've I you know we just broke up
[ __ ] it sucks dude I don't even know it
every it really [ __ ] sucks and I
don't even know what I'm thinking four I
was just about a [ __ ] trade in my
iPhone today perfectly fine no cracks in
two [ __ ] years just about to trade it
in and get money back on it cracked it
literally 10 [ __ ] minutes ago so I
don't know what to do dude it feels like
life's just [ __ ] beating me down this
past two months I don't know that's not
even everything but help me hey Chris
and Matt you wanna know something I
don't even see my lip yet you wanna know
something even funnier it was my
birthday yesterday like I said and I got
jumped I got [ __ ] the [ __ ] kicked out
of me by like
I don't even know there was four of us
and there was like 15 of them
I don't know some dudes tried to fight
my cousin Emily literally walked up
started pushing her yelling in her face
trying to [ __ ] fight her and then I
got involved I wasn't letting that
happen and hurt one of them and started
hurting number one and then ended up
having six people kicking me in the
[ __ ] face and I'd blacked out
I don't know I honestly don't remember
it at all my [ __ ]
my nose is lit though
oh inside of my lips oh I can't even
pick it up holding to my lips off dude
okay
there's a third set on fire got broken
up with got jumped all in like the same
month
what's up hey Chris and Matt what's
going on I got jumped
I don't really have any advice that I
got to ask for in this video
faces all swollen up nose is split it's
like seven years
but
I got a Chihuahua from bubbaku so
I think I'm all right today
I think I'm all right
dude that's the fourth video because
Matt what's up died yesterday
he's got gray hair and [ __ ] dirt keeps
popping on his face or shoveling so what
do you do when you're dead
the dirt in my mouth can't get out
because my body won't move uh don't know
how to ask for it so anyway if you could
help anyway Chris come to see you in
Cleveland
um
first of all
I mean this guy well okay so life's
going a little better you got the
[ __ ]
higher Spirits [ __ ] vibing out with
his [ __ ] thing that he got whatever
it is I will say he did seem 30 in the
first video and then 50. yeah he seems
48 in the last time sorry sorry he
seemed 20 and then 30. right
um so uh
my God that was funny all right I'm
Sorry by the way the burns got better I
didn't see Burns in the second one it
must have gotten better I mean it
sounded like the second video was long
after the first one but I don't know
okay uh my god well you know what you
got a pretty good [ __ ] attitude I'll
give you that great attitude you know
you got set on fire you got you broken
up with you you got beat the [ __ ] out of
and jumped sounds like maybe it was a
little bit your fault um but yeah no you
don't know maybe the fire was your fault
too if his cousin is his female cousin
is getting the [ __ ] kicked out of her
no he said that they started to start a
fight with her but it could be an
argument oh I take things very they
started pushing her he said oh they did
okay
um yeah man that's uh I don't know man I
mean do buckaroos what do you get a
[ __ ] what do you get at buckaroos
the Chihuahua from babarus Bubba coos I
mean it sounds so racist wow bubbakoos
this whole thing what culture is it it's
so weird is it Asian is it so busy that
menu that's so crazy bubbakoos
you know wow
um yeah man just keep going to bubbaku's
and getting and and you know life rips
so uh you know this is the there's the
moments that uh that make you right but
for real though for real when life is
bad it just seems to and therefore does
just get actual worse yeah it does yeah
you're thinking about it right and it's
just like an energy thing and it's just
you kind of it turns into this cycle
where one thing leads to the next leads
to the next snowballs and snowballs and
snowballs and it's hard to get out of
that [ __ ] vicious cycle but
eventually the cycle warms and thin and
[ __ ] thaws out and it ends up being
gone forever and Chris is doing the
really annoying thing that he does but
the thing about bad times is that we
don't remember politicians have gone
through them before and every time we're
in a bad time it seems like the end of
the [ __ ] world but the truth is it's
just another bad time in a series of
many bad times Potter's broken up by
that's right good times vote for me so
very soon overcome you will forget about
this bad time but try not to forget
about the bad time because next time the
bad time comes you want to remember
you want to remember the bad times
before because you got through them
before and you'll get through it again
even if you get burned jumped girlfriend
breaks up with you on your iPhone breaks
all within a span of a few days there
will always be that public who's yeah
Chihuahua exactly
um the metaphorical metaphorical
Chihuahua from bubbakoos you will always
be able to get that bubbakoo's Chihuahua
even though babaku's will not be around
for that much longer because it is a
horrible it's clearly gonna go out of
business yeah but but
uh seems like you're taking care of your
[ __ ]
um Burns and your moons will heal but
bubbakus will always be there for you
and that's why life rips It won't always
be there for you they'll go out of
business yeah we'll definitely go oh
maybe it sounds like it's like a popular
thing there like in and out here or some
[ __ ] the way he said it maybe made it
sound like it's something we should know
man how much was like the boat fire so
his fault like it was inarguably his
fault oh yeah you know like literally
was smoking next to gasoline yes and
then also the fight was so his fault
yeah yeah yeah the fight was so his
fault yeah yeah yeah and then breaking
up was so yeah definitely right [ __ ]
was cheating and left his texts out and
we had porn playing on his computer and
just was like a sybian porn and was and
was drawing a [ __ ] Banner that said
[ __ ] my girlfriend I hate her
yeah all right uh do we have another one
all right cool wow that one was funny I
mean not I'm sad well yesterday I was
outside doing my chores and raking up
leaves when I hit a wasp nest oh no they
attacked me and
chased me into my house into the shower
and just kept staying me oh I got stung
15 times now I'm scared to go to my
backyard to finish
breaking up the leaves what should I do
oh my they followed her in the house
it's like a [ __ ] out for the
Hitchcock movie here's what you do you
call uh animal and Wildlife you gotta
call Batman and they will get rid of the
wasp nest for you if you don't want to
involve uh animal and wild authorities
if you don't want to involve the
authorities uh go out your front door go
get some [ __ ] raid or you know wasp
killer wasp killer no go the [ __ ] out
there was a big thing over your head and
the gloves on and long sleeves long long
pants and long sleeves and just go out
spraying
I say do with a bow and arrow dude then
you gotta you gotta have 15 arrows at
least you have a lot more than that dude
yeah if you're gonna get each B at a
time
um Jesus she was outside doing [ __ ] and
they followed her into her house then
they followed her in the shower dude
don't be them bees don't give a [ __ ] huh
I got stung by a [ __ ] vicious thing
dude the other maybe a couple weeks ago
I had the biggest [ __ ] welt on my
upper leg where it stung me you take
care of his [ __ ] crazy like you were
rubbing creams on it and using like
constricting pants and stuff yeah I
don't do that I I like to do [ __ ] to my
body I don't do that any chance I get
whether it's like a [ __ ] take a
milligram a rap or a [ __ ] ointment a
tincture that's crazy spread why do you
like doing that a stick I like sticks
that you go like that and rub on your
shoes why well I mean why not not for no
reason no no but why why I want the
thing that's wrong with me to go away
that's why yeah okay yeah interesting so
that's awesome that itches like a
[ __ ] right I want to get it over
with as soon as possible and you believe
in the ointments I mean if it's
cortisone yeah I don't like buy like
some people don't believe in the
ointments what do you mean what is the
doctor's like this will work I'm like
why do you not believe the dog What's It
Gonna help a day like What's it gonna
make it go away for a day a day sooner
do you know what I'm saying
I'm dummy I'm a dumb I'm dumb I guess I
mean a day sooner is good though I guess
I would use it I just don't have like
having to take [ __ ] and stuff wow that
sucks man bees in the shower bees in the
shower bees bees in the shower yeah bees
in the shower bees be dude Calvin loves
bees in the trap the song by Nicki Minaj
okay and he and he calls it he thinks
it's beans in the trap oh can I watch
beans in the trap it's so cute dude oh
dude this dog on my laps this dog in my
lapse [ __ ] crazy dreams right now
just shaking like crazy the worst Johnny
Cash song of all time this dog in my
life is having crazy or even crazy
shaking she just woke up okay well she
doesn't like Johnny Cash okay so
unprofessional doing this on the [ __ ]
podcast
do do
Oney ew
ew oh l
it's gross huh she was on my lap the
whole episode
well okay the crotch is warm
I mean the the crotch is warm
you know like it's the end of all the
crotches it's the crotch yeah the crotch
is warm I have the crotch all right
what's next
none
okay
[ __ ] Irish or English
oh Matt and Chris this is Vladimir from
Belarus damn it and uh I am an English
teacher online I have many students and
I have an option to uh deny them a
service uh if I don't like them
um good for you Jesus and basically
um
I have this one student who is
um a married woman
and
um I wouldn't say that I have feelings
for this person but oh I've been uh
thinking about her a little bit too much
those are called over the past a few
months and uh lately I love her the
atmosphere during our lessons
um became a little too personal oh boy
and
um so I feel a little uh strange
considering the fact that she's married
so
um I want some advice
um what should I do should I deny her uh
and
uh discontinue our lessons
or should I uh consider of our lessons
and
yeah
strange
um
every time I see her and
um
this is my question oh so
um thank you for your opinion and uh I
love this show uh thanks so much and
um has one facial expression dude
I mean don't who cares dude like yeah
you got to deal with it what what is
what is even going on that is so like
Troublesome it is mainly
um we are personal but also my banner is
uh yeah it's like are you poking are you
able to focus and just focus on the
assignment and like the lesson if you
are then keep doing it like what do you
mean by personal you like what are we
talking about like talking about one
another sex lives are we just talking
about like
your usual home life is right the dog
jumped over the lazy fox and she's like
I squirt he's like oh oh right yeah
um I squirt but my husband doesn't make
me squirt anything this morning oh oh
dude I I feel like uh you know you're
just dealing with like you could be
asking she could literally be like you
could say all the stars and she'd be
like what right exactly so like you got
to be careful but I love how he started
with uh I could deny her lessons if I
want right like yeah no [ __ ] man you
could overreact and do that but just
like whatever also man like
I'd like to know what she's doing
he said he doesn't have feelings for her
in the beginning I don't have feelings
for her but I have to say if that's the
case then who gives a [ __ ]
what does he mean he didn't specify and
that's what's bothering me like what do
you mean too personal maybe he didn't
specify he's not great at English it's
obviously it's his second language
but he's an English teacher so he should
know yeah
um dude this is um
maybe all in your head it may not be but
keep keep
don't do anything because you're in the
authority position I don't know how it
is in [ __ ] wherever you are but like
make sure you just
keep it strictly the way it is and if
she gets a little if she I don't know
what too personal is if she gets super
if she touches you or anything like that
or says what are you doing later that's
when you shut it down right you got to
just keep it professional strictly
professional think about whatever you
got to think about but don't do anything
beyond the thinking right
and try very hard not to get a bone
doggy definitely not yeah
without question I'm sorry I bumped your
arm while you were writing English it
wasn't me it was my bone doggy yeah
that's right yeah I don't know what to
tell you man but that's uh that's what
I'm telling you
and that's that
is indeed that well it's checked out at
the end there so what are you talking
about no come on I'm with you guys
thanks for watching uh
well that's what's up dude I'll be in
New York just [ __ ] sold 60 tickets
today already that's a lot it is a lot
and uh it's not even noon so it's noon
it's noon so
um I'll be in New York February 18th get
the tickets I'll be in January I'll be
in January I'll be in uh Seattle and uh
also Portland and San Diego added a
second show there and I will be in
Boston most importantly coming up next
week
November 12th the first show sold out
still tickets for the second show
selling out um and uh you can get the
merch at uh uh what is a watch Lifeline
what is it
Laughlin merch.com lifelinemerch.com and
go to chrisley.com for tickets for sure
you go to matdalia.com for private
sessions with me private advice sessions
with me
is that it if you have a question
I love you yeah I love you too okay the
question go to email it on the bottom
yeah
someone has our parents held captions
[Music]